we've been having this discussion for a
long time and the the main question of
the discussion is why does Donald Trump
lie about such meaningless things in
provably demonstrably false ways right
he appears to be a pathological liar
that's been one assessment or maybe not
there's new reporting from the
Washington Post in The New York Times
which is very interesting and if you pay
close attention to what these reports
say it seems to suggest there's a
growing theory that trumps not lying
when he says this insane stuff but that
Trump may actually be delusional and
might believe it now what do I mean by
that Donald Trump reportedly lies in
private in front of just a few people in
his inner circle about many of the same
things that he lies about in public he
might actually be this disconnected from
reality here's one example the birther
thing with the former President Barack
Obama it's been long resolved right
President Obama he has a birth
certificate he was born in the US
whatever Trump in private reportedly
still talks about how he doesn't believe
Obama was born in the United States
there's no evidence for that in private
Donald Trump is still saying he doesn't
know where President Obama was born he
thinks that the birth certificate may
have been doctored another example voter
fraud Donald Trump said publicly after
the 2016 election that he would have won
the popular vote were it not for 3 to 5
million people who illegally voted for
Hillary Clinton he is reportedly
continuing to talk about that in private
which again suggests he might really
believe it it's not just to rile up his
base Trump is in private telling people
that special prosecutor Robert Muller is
going to end his investigation into
possible Russian collusion by the end of
this year it's a month away we have only
three indictments so far and one guilty
plea from george papadapolis there is no
way in hell that this thing is wrapping
up by the end of the year it's not even
likely to be perfectly frank that it
wraps up by the end of 2018 and Trump is
in private reportedly saying that it's
going to end within a month earlier this
week I told you that now Donald Trump is
the authenticity of that infamous Access
Hollywood grab him by the you-know-what
recording and we wondered how is it that
Donald Trump is questioning the
authenticity of something he already
admitted was real and apologized for he
is reportedly continuing to question the
authenticity of the grabbing by the you
know what tapes in private Donald Trump
might truly believe that the Access
Hollywood tape was doctored now there's
a couple possibilities here if we try to
understand this one is well maybe Trump
is lying even to his own staff and he
knows that he's lying
but that would be really weird right
like what what would be the point of
Trump lying even in a room with just a
few of his closest advisers about this
stuff it really doesn't make sense but
it would sort of explain why Trump holds
such pointless and self-defeating lies
over and over again which is he really
believes them and he's not connected to
reality so I think that this is a very
interesting thing we know that Trump
watches Fox and Friends and takes it as
gospel he repeats conspiracy theories
from Infowars he genuinely might not
even realize that Russia manipulated him
throughout the election Trump might be
actually telling us what he sees as the
truth and if he is just delusional it
kind of exonerates him in some way well
because then he's not lying right then
he's not going out there and trying to
deceive I mean it would make him unfit
to be President but it's not unethical
really it would make him less of a
despised Abul guy but even more clearly
unfit for the presidency right if you
think about for a second what's more
dangerous a president who lies that
climate change is a hoax created by the
Chinese in order to further his own
political goals or a president who
actually believes that climate change is
a hoax created by the Chinese I think
it's far more dangerous to have a guy in
the Oval Office who believes that than
the guy who's lying about it to rile up
is certainly more dangerous so the what
how does this connect to some of the
other stuff we've been talking about
well we don't want to diagnose people
from afar but there have been a number
of different medical experts who say you
know Donald Trump might be experiencing
early signs of dementia it's unclear
whether he may be cognitively limited in
some other ways this level of delusion
where Donald Trump actually believes
this stuff may in some way fit into that
and it can become you know delusions in
general delusions of grandeur which
Donald Trump certainly has and just
general delusions of easily demonstrably
provably false ideas from the real world
that can kind of interrelate with signs
and symptoms of dementia as well it can
be sort of hard to distinguish will we
ever really know the answer I genuinely
have no idea I genuinely have no idea
there was ever a time to use the
twenty-fifth amendment I think it would
be now already so and that's another and
and I know people write in all the time
they say David the impeachment for
Russia stuff isn't going to happen if
there's going to be a removal of trump
from presidents from the presidency it's
going to be in an invocation of the
twenty-fifth amendment which I think
generally pat is something like if the
president is determined to be incapable
of doing the basic tasks of office I
don't remember how many members we get
together and impeach him in that way
they would decide in a different way
yeah I don't think any of it's going to
happen but increasingly there's as
strong a case being made for a use of
the 25th amendment as there is for the
Russia collusion stuff send me your
thoughts on that last question though
what's worse Trump lying about some of
these things or Trump actually believing
some of these things which do you think
is worth I think that the delusion part
is much more concerning in terms of his
fitness for the presidency I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is made possible in part by
movement watches I've been wearing my
movement watch I actually have two of
them at this point for more than a year
really like them get complements
everywhere I go they look like watches
that would cost four or five hundred
dollars in a department store but
because movement sells directly to you
skipping the retail markup and the
middleman the watches started just
ninety five bucks and they make really
great gifts they make especially good
gifts if you're like me and you hate
going to the mall standing in lines
wading through people who just can't
seem to get off the stairs and let you
walk by and again the
watches start at just 95 bucks skipped
the crowd skip the lines movement has
now sold over a million watches in a
hundred and sixty countries and you can
get 15% off with free shipping and free
returns by going to M V M t.com slash
Pakman that's MVM t.com /p a que ma n
15% off free shipping free returns